first time you made an amount of money
that made your jaw drop what was that
story you're like holy [ __ ] i can't
believe this just happened what was that
my first deal uh i did with foot locker
i got like 100 grand like
first year working yeah on social media
yeah and i went from making 400 bucks a
week right you know for whatever i
believe you did an ad campaign for foot
locker
david if you could put up mike holston
foot locker i'm sure it'll pop right up
yeah explain that to you
it's just you know going back to the
passion thing you know like where where
i'm working at and what i'm doing in my
life doesn't there's no money in it
there's no
you can't look at anybody on tv and be
like yo i'm my father's rich
and doing what i'm doing because there's
no money in it there's no money in the
animals there's no money in the animal
yeah you know when you've got to get the
corporate answers the most money you're
going to make as a looking at an animal
as anyone who
wants to do animals you're going to be a
veterinarian you're going to make
60 to maybe 90 000 a year being a vet
being a vet tech
i'm cool i don't want to be a vet tech
you know did you ever go to school i
wanted to i never can afford it good
thing you then go yeah you're the numb
as much yeah there you go
i want to go back to school though one
day don't waste your money you want to
go back to school for herpetology
rheumatology yeah that's what i always
want to do since a kid plants
herpetologists is just a a person that
studies reptiles and amphibians gotcha
you know and i want to do botany too and
back to back to the the the jaw dropping
story with foot locker explain this
right here so yeah man um
welcome to the tarzan show hey
[Music]
exciting to see each other this guy is
called the panther chameleon the most
colorful chameleon in the world his eyes
they can see in front of him and behind
him at the same time that's called
vision 20 years ago my vision was set
with animals my love for sneakers stems
deep i take them out in the wild i clean
elephant poop in them i jump in canals
to save turtles
the whole nine so if i buy some shoes
that everybody's drooling over and they
want to put them on ice i'm not that guy
communication with animals i started
when i was a kid if you have a good
energy you have a good heart these
animals can sense more than we can sense
studying them being around them they
became my best friends these little
frogs down here they're called dumpy
tree frogs they actually turn blue the
bluest ones only have one eye to call
them cyclops frogs what would you do
jungles meet the og's on our feet i
would you hyper blue
discover your air
sick bro
everything you do is on brand with who
you are like that didn't feel forced or
faked like you can feel his heart like
hey looking at your smile and i just
love it
i can't believe he's got a girlfriend
all right let's just let's let's let's
go easy on the map